we said goodbye to Hanna we sprayed
ourselves into champagne gate she's safe
and is this already the most emotional
season of The Bachelor ever letter to us
this is your bachelor season 24 episode
to recap grab your glasses it's time for
roses and roses a hi you guys it's me
Lauren Zima where am I
Oh everybody this is our new sets I told
you it was going to happen we've got a
new blank ad oh it's so fresh so soft so
sexual we've got a new couch oh it's so
mod so beautiful so chic we've got
something new to keep our wines cold
both aesthetically pleasing and a super
freakin functional we've got a bomber
card
and look at this everybody look at this
because planes so this everybody is our
new set for 2020 same show new look same
studio different feel save me more wine
and I am so excited about it in 2020 my
personal mantra is chic only yeah only
she in 2020 as always let me know in the
comments below what your thoughts on our
new look are and share your mantra for
2020 what do you guys doing how are you
feeling cheers to the new year but now
the bachelor during the woman said no to
me let's get to it alright so we might
be moving into the future but Peter is
still living in the past we open this
episode where we left off
Hannah and Peter talking and that
looming windmill of doom so we're on the
group sex date you know I'm saying group
date or they're gonna talk about sex and
Peter is spending all this time with
Hannah don't drink every time one of the
other women says where's Peter
I need Peter where's Peter yeah Hannah
appears to have liked some of the
mascara off so that's nice but we can't
get a clear look because this is the
shakiest camera I've ever seen on this
show
is this camera person tired are they
alright how long is this conversation
been going I can't feel what I feel I
just do they're talking and they're
talking and are they getting anything
accomplished Hannah says she's confused
I don't know she just says maybe we
should catch a flight fight but she also
isn't definitively asking Peter for
anything clear Peter says I don't know
what to do right now but I don't blame
him it is not a tangible definitive
thing that she is requesting
Canha do you want to join the show do
you want him to pick up and go do you
know I don't think so
ultimately what Peter does is just gives
us a casual bomb drop out of nowhere and
he says I can't do this what can't you
do I'm not sure I think whatever it
would be with Hannah is what he's saying
did you know okay
tell me what you guys alternately
thought of this conversation shameless
plug I did interview Peter here at
Entertainment Tonight and he told me
that he was still in love with Hannah at
this point in the season I don't know if
you completely ever lose that for
someone a hundred percent and I think
you guys saw yeah a lot of that
resurface it was just it was very real
yes ultimately my take is that they
didn't break up that long ago obviously
they haven't been able to really escape
each other they're both in the media
talking about the shows and I think when
you see an ex that newly feelings just
come up you know tell me mm oh god all
that I've already drink a lot of wine so
I was confused and they also said some
things I literally didn't understand was
Peters saying did you do this to me did
Hannah say this is not what was supposed
to happen I don't know bad audio I don't
know that camera worked that audio do
better okay yeah just kidding this shows
the gift that keeps on giving I love it
so much didn't give Han a very good
mascara good thing okay I'm just not the
right ad space right now so just enjoy
this and then don't drink for every
casual bomb drop then Peter tells the
other women he's canceling the rest of
the day I don't think today we can
continue with this with this group date
Oh JC gasps about what I saw that I'm so
distraught I need to cuddle our new
fuzzy soft blanket for comfort Oh
some nice I'll be honest with you guys
that last blanket wasn't even a blanket
it was a cheap table runner I got an
Amazon Prime it really upgraded 2020 she
only okay oh I'm hot in this sweater but
it's chic it's so chic keep being chic
they say beauty is pain chic is sweaty
every she could explain you guys the
sweat inside my pants here just kind of
a pleather pant you know these studio
lights that's sticky I'm like Rossum
that episode of friends my god these
pants burning oh did you feel this was
warranted by Peter I get that he was
upset about Hannah but I'll be honest it
felt unfair to the women they had all
been waiting there and then they were
just sent away he did apologize but I
honestly thought he should have powered
through sorry I will see you all later
yes by the way I will just say I do love
Peter how are you guys feeling about
Peter so far as the bachelor many people
wanted Tyler many people wanted Mike but
Peter is showing the emotions and with
all the tears we have this episode I
feel like this might already be the most
emotional season of The Bachelor ever
also Peter told me he has cried more
than any other bachelor shameless blood
so the group sex date is cancelled but
the women do reconvene for the little
cocktail party by the way a lot of color
in that room a different look did anyone
else notice this do we have a new set
designer for the show did they get a new
set just like us
do dock moving forward shake only in
2020 okay all here repeater but no one
spend time with him so it's still new we
still don't know the woman and this
woman whose name I don't know makes a
really good point she says that hannah
has essentially been the whole season so
far everyday I've seen you I've seen her
very much
no I don't want this to happen I don't
want it to be like how in Hannah season
we got so Luke P focused and we got
really burnt out on that storyline I
don't want Hannah to be Peters whole
season unless she sticks around and they
end up together I don't know but that's
what I'm saying what you guys think so
cheers to her good point
oh and then this other woman I don't
know yet makes another great point she
says Peter do you want your past to be
your presence like do you want that to
be your pastor do you want to be your
present Wow Wow in this emotive season
I'm gonna say that this is going to be
the deep emotional question of the week
I just hope that we can move past this
together so perhaps quite an intelligent
group of women I also think very
beautiful
a stunning crowd let me know your
thoughts in the comments below okay I
got to tell you guys if I were there I
would be frustrated by the Peter Hannah
thing how would you feel to me sir if
I'm gonna date you I'm trying to date
you not be your therapist I'm saying I'm
not here to help you work out your
issues with your ex I gotta go is there
wine in this mansion okay bye then I
wrote down god I gotta look up this
one's name because she makes another
great point she says you canceled a date
you go cancel a date with these people
the nerve the Tasha her name is Natasha
do you agree with Natasha
but Peter seems to be moving forward and
by moving forward I mean making out on a
woman with a counter again I mean of
course we had Hannah on the pool table
then last week we had Kelly on the bar
and now we have McKenna on the I don't
know what it was on but Wow
sir I counter your counter with this
couch and you go there so I'm so excited
to hear how your champagne and then we
got it's been on my counter for over a
year
Oh everybody buckle up because Kelsey's
taking us on a bumpy ride isn't she at
first I was thinking god this woman is
gorgeous and I was thinking oh my god
she wants to bring champagne to peter
share a bottle champagne with him that
I've been saving for a really special
moment
I love her can I date her and then
things took a turn I am excited for
tonight
Kelsey I've been wanting to do something
special with Peter
so she's been saving this bottle of Dom
Perignon for like a year and I'm a
hopeless romantic I love love and she
brought it to the show from Iowa Wow did
you check a back I hate checking her
back carry on only okay travel light you
never know when you might have to go off
the grid and flee anyway go talk mama
bear yes she's on a mission first
McKenna steals Peter amigo hot when
Kelsey wanted her moment and she freaks
how did her don't expect my sympathy
don't expect anyone else's sympathy did
you feel that this reaction was
over-the-top I did so Kelsey is swearing
at her I had something planned I wanted
to do it quickly got the Sigma Kenna
disrespected her and you disrespected me
she said I don't tolerate snakes
they're my least favorite thanks our
least favorite animal done we have a
quick reprieve a nice moment with
Madison she's back she's very sweet what
do you guys think of Madison Peter seems
very into her he gave her a framed photo
of him and his family oh my god
and they're doing nuzzles I seemed so in
love I also just wanted to shout out I
couldn't come but notice
Madison really says her words but back
to the champagne talks about what you
want to talk about talk about your
champagne let's talk about your
champagne so Kelsey is set up the
champagne and she's talking to the other
women about how special it is I'm really
excited I have got a redemption to like
share with him tonight they're all
saying they know how special it is right
he's like I'm not gonna tell y'all
yes Kelsey Darragh where that she set it
up yes they know what's right over there
don't go over there
yes Kelsey no one should touch the
champagne like it's big deal you know
everyone is perfectly in the know about
the level of importance of the champagne
and the champagne is special sentimental
video the champagne is important oh I'm
so excited
nobody else better touch the champagne
you know what this was building up to
let's do it never in my life have I been
more afraid to hear the sound of
champagne we got a so sweaty okay
[Music]
what's that I heard a pop I did don't so
someone else
popped Telsey [ __ ] who's with him we
don't know huh and she is losing it she
is crying she is breaking down I don't
want to be a girl don't really make up
this Howarth it you don't know it's
probably not and of course who was it
everybody did just see it coming
excuse me it was Hannah Anna I think
it's just Hannah Ann but I wish it was
Hannah Anna too much I don't know so
Hannah drank Kelsey champagne that she
brought from Des Moines Iowa to bring to
Peter and Kelsey is going off the rails
I think she know what she was doing she
just she's a Sikh and don't drink every
time she mentions her least favorite
animal that snake
she's a Sikh do you think she's a snake
in st. yeah now a parade of women is
following Kelsey up parade do not drink
for every woman following Kelsey
I'm not okay I don't like this you guys
know I don't want to go talk to Peter I
mean I've been saving that I might add
her for a year or what yeah this is her
body she brought from home
what no Anna Anne says she had no idea
that that was Kelsey's champagne she
says there was a champagne mix-up
apparently there was a mixup of the
champagne a game is afoot
I'm mystery abounding who did it who
done it where with what who do you
believe let me know in the comments
below
so Kelsey's like gathering herself and
she's finally gonna go talk to Peter and
they're gonna drink not her champagne
but the sad unspecial champagne we can
open it okay we might need a drink and
let's have a drink and that's when
things get really dark drinking from the
bottle or from the tub because one thing
Kelsey has going for her right now is
that she looks absolutely flawless I'm
not a classy [ __ ] all the time very
good I hang it she's trying to show
Peter I'm not freaking out I'm fine I'm
silly and I'm chillin I can drink
champagne right out of the bottle and
then this happens
[Music]
okay how did she do that I don't even
understand it I mean like maybe I'm an
expert but I don't know how she
accomplished that is it physics let me
know in the comments below maybe I'm not
champagne aware enough okay but this
isn't knives out Daniel Craig isn't here
suspect on the mystery isn't solved you
up to something that bleh in a champagne
bottle and think that that's for you
Kelsey is confronting Hanna and and
drink every time Hanna says that she has
acknowledged Kelsey's feelings I ignored
your feelings I've acknowledged your
feelings and I've apologized but you're
gonna apologize I've acknowledged your
feelings I respect your opinion did you
feel like she did let me know whose side
you guys were on here I will say that
Tammy said Kelsey was little she's a hot
mess and she said oh and I do see that
the reactions aren't matching up with
the actions you know I mean reaction is
something that matches up for the action
a paralleled move something that is
equal in response to I'm saying ten-four
sorry to interrupt Peter Chris it's time
for your second rose ceremony so come
join me all right Oh
but these producers are the gift that
keeps on giving those two are standing
right next to each other at the rose
ceremony
ladies I'm sorry did not receive a rose
take a moment say your goodbyes
and some women we don't know are going
home but when is a girl named Lauren
booth goodbye good luck worn by there
are eight 19 girls left and I think
there's still tension built up a new
look and some new moves this season
we're seeing the morning-after for the
women they're eating breakfast Tami's in
like a cue ball moment this was unusual
I liked it Kelsey's depressing Dom has
not yet been cleaned up I have someone
drinking I mean that's just a waste you
know Dom Perignon and the gift that
keeps on giving shockingly Hannah Anne
and Kelsey that is hard to say are both
on the group date I can't believe it
I have three very special guests oh and
it's a revolved date very on Buran do
you know that the brand ribald has
gotten very involved with all the
bachelor gals on the instagrams great
one of the first members of your eyes
Fab Five Carson Kressley
so Carson Kressley of queer eye is here
and supermodel Janice Dickinson is here
and one of the big execs from revolve is
here and ladies this is an opportunity
right I'm gonna make a good impression
on this one Hannah and even get a
modeling gig I thought there would be
more between Hannah and and Kelsey
Kelsey
Hannah Anne and Hannah and I'm fine
it's been very emotional and I need this
still so cold still so chilly but some
other women come to the forefront
Victoria s is back I can't really get a
handle on her yet she is a woman who
came to the mansion and made one of the
dirtiest intro line jokes we've ever had
but now she's saying that she's not
confident I don't know what to say he
doesn't know how to see him out in a
crowd she's really overwhelmed okay just
like overgrown anger there's feel like
other girl asleep
oh I felt for her this process is
probably so crazy this first couple of
days when you're meeting all new people
you've left all your people behind
you're just trying to adjust what did
you guys think I'm looking for character
diva personality so the women are doing
the fashion show and Janice Dickinson is
like you better standout personality I
don't totally know what she meant by
that but Hana and decided to walk down
as a bride
so that was bold and noticeable great
cheers to Hana and you're not drink
every time someone blew a kiss at Peter
[Music]
so Victoria F is now an F for freaking
out I'm scared I was honestly worried
for her I was like is this gonna be a
Victoria F for fall is she gonna eat it
oh but she did it she made it and then
it became Victoria after ferocious
Victoria after fierce Victoria I've
forgiven no ABS you know what I'm saying
cuz she walked down that runway in
lingerie
very good
I like the count more though you know I
was more focused on matters ago where's
that coat from but then it became
Victoria asked for freaking highs and
lows just when I was liking her just
when I was supporting her just when I
was cheering her on she loses it I'm
done
and now she's crying just cuz she didn't
win saying she's done here she wants to
leave girl get it together
don't be so affected I mean drink every
time someone had a meltdown this episode
I forgot Peter I'd have meltdown in the
beginning of the episode we had Peter we
had Kelsey at Victoria we kind of had
the dump and yo oh god it's speaking of
now we're bringing champagne gate back
after last night with the champagne
scandal man I will never look I
champagne the same again what do we want
to call it
I mean interviews Chris Harrison has
called it champagne gate Hannah Anne was
calling it the champagne scandal I'm
calling it champagne full okay it's
painful I'm over it already
don't bring champagne into this it
deserves better okay again I did it
expertly I don't know what was the
problem it's just so excited to drink it
waiting for so long would she have spin
the Dom pérignon out this is the cheap
one okay
elevated ratchet everybody we're on a
beautiful set our champagne costs $2.99
I felt bullied
and it was really really really really
hard and then champagne full turns into
the Battle of the bullying Hannah Ann
tells Peter that Kelsey's been bullying
her what did you guys think the word
bully is a big one to throw around it
had quite a cultural media moment a
couple of years ago and since then a lot
of gravity has been added to that word
you can't just say it casually it's
quite an accusation I acknowledge that
we don't see everything that happens in
the house so maybe Kelsey was repeatedly
coming after Hannah Ann but what I saw
was Kelsey freaking out in a fight I
don't know if I'd say she was bullying
her let me know in the comments below
then things are done but we get a peek
into next week next week on The Bachelor
I'm not a Champaign Stewart I just would
never do that to someone why would I
steal champagne and it's more tears and
is more sexuality and it's more of
Peter's mother crying I can't watch that
clip much more you guys it's very
difficult for me she's so lovely and
she's like it's like really hard to
watch I feel like I am in a Meryl Streep
movie
I have such doubts and I don't mean that
like she's acting I just mean that's the
gravitas with which this is hitting me
okay everybody so happy for our new set
so loving this season of The Bachelor
how do you feel what do you think are
you having a meltdown let me know in the
comments below as always I'm available
on cameo if you want a personal message
from me and please do follow me over on
the instagrams and the Twitter I live
tweet the episodes and say different
things when I say here Wow how many
thoughts can be inside of this in too
many personalities I love you guys so
much babe
[Music]
you